Heather McDonald is the author of the
diversity of delusion and she joins us
tonight Heather thanks very much for
coming on thank you so just in the past
24 hours you've been rethinking this
question we sort of jumped headlong into
the mocking of Joe Biden which was fun I
will say but then I heard Nancy Pelosi
say what we just played her saying which
is we really ought to approach other
people as if we all have colds and have
a arm's length relationship with people
we're not related to what kind of
society is she describing in in human
one Tucker one where there is no
forgiveness there is no acceptance of
differences of behavior we're all
supposed to be for diversity right how
about accepting the diversity of an
older generation that has a different
style of engagement that has not been
terrorized into frigid self-criticism by
the feminist harpies that cannot
understand that there are different
human beings there are different ways of
relating to people this is this is going
to end normal human intercourse as we
know it if if they're allowed to get
away with this these females have all
said there was nothing sexual about it
okay the conversation should end there
but the new standard now that feminists
are setting is they determine by their
subjective experience the character of
experiences there's no reasonable
persons standard we're certainly not
going to accept the male's view that as
Biden said I had no intention to offend
anybody I was not intending anything
sexual none of that matters now if a
feminist feels offended then the
interaction is objectively offensive and
that is a recipe for chaos and
alienation I think you're exactly right
a recipe for what we have which is chaos
and alienation increasingly so I think a
lot of us me I'll speak for myself I
looked at this and there something
amusing about watching the left eat
itself because they have to adhere to
their own ludicrous dinners they're
living in the PC hell they created for
the rest of us but what's happening to
to Joe Biden is what they plan for the
rest of us uh-huh and what's he plans
for everybody else
so when it's hard not to take a certain
fiendish Glee in this yeah because it's
certainly turn around is fair play
this is a man who unleashed the war on
due process in campus tribunals who has
unleashed every single feminist trope
about phantom rape culture for the last
three decades you says belief survivors
so it's purely just what he's getting
nevertheless I urge you Tucker to step
above pure political vendetta and say no
what's at stake here is the livability
of human society young people have to
understand old people people have to be
a little flexible but the the feminist
worldview is brittle its intolerant its
unforgiving and it's utterly
narcissistic these females are saying
their worldview their subjective
experience should be now the norm for
everybody else regardless of whether it
is objectively reasonable what their
what their interpretation is so what
would you say to non liberals the
temptation is always going to be to
engage in exactly the behavior that you
criticize in others in other words you
know they're destroying politicians
Bernie Sanders apparently or maybe
leaked this against Joe Biden so now
conservatives can become every bit as
aggrieved yes and use the same style but
that is a trap I think absolutely you
have to realize that precedent principle
matters and the precedent that you're
setting will be used against you there
there's always changes of power and and
the ideal for human experience is to
live by something that is not sheer
partisan vengeance and to set principles
that you're happy to live with for
yourself and for other people so again
in this case as tempting as Biden is as
a target and certainly you know he's the
strongest contender against Donald Trump
but his real sin is just his own history
that's stoking the feminist Furies again
we should not go down that path because
I can guarantee you there's going to be
a whole line of Republican politicians
who deserve to succeed who are going to
have photos taken of them when they've
got an arm around right nobody just
simply because they are a physical human
being and I'll tell you the other thing
that we can see where this is taking us
Antioch College which was
we marked in 1994 it's affirmative
consent policy for drunken campus
hookups and said every every last grope
has to be explicitly agreed to it
everybody said this is crazy two decades
later every college has no that's that's
exactly that's now they are applying
affirmative consent to platonic touch
now a daughter objects to her mother
hugging her because she didn't get
consent this is where this is going to
take us Tucker
it really is dystopian it is kind of
sterile world it's a surreal world
honest McDonald I can't think of anyone
who could have explained that better
than you just did thank you very much
thank you so much Tucker